thank you for coming everyone I'm Evan I
designed this programming language Elm
and I've been working on it over 10
years now and I wanted to share what I
learned that I I wanted I would want to
have heard when I started out as a
student um so when I was at University I
was finishing up my undergraduate and I
was doing my thesis and I was reading
all these papers and I thought they were
so cool and I had this feeling that
there was this you know somewhere out
there there's this big hallway of
beautiful ideas and you don't you don't
get to just see them you have to stand
in front of it and be patient and be
diligent and if you wait long enough and
you read the right things and you look
from the right angle this fog lifts and
you get to see the beautiful thing in
there and it was always in there but now
you get to see it and you can show other
people hey check it out the fog's not
there you can see it and that's not to
say that like
it's something that's properly
transcendently it's just like to me at
that moment I was like ah I got I
figured it out I found out what was
behind the fog and so for me working on
a program language was always this kind
of intrinsic motivation of I I want to
be able to find out about these
things um and as I worked on it I I was
very lucky to to have people support my
work and through that I would meet other
language designers compiler writers
virtual machine people and I'd hear
things like um there's nine Engineers
working on rest I like oh okay that kind
of makes sense you know it's a bigger
language and it's got this school
compiler and 10 Engineers on Swift I was
like oh okay um and at some point I
heard there 30 Engineers on Dart and I
was just like was like that's that's
fine but I don't I just can't account
for H what would happen with that many
people um because from my perspective
you know I'm I'm fresh out of college
and I'm like the job is you do some
engineering right you write a compiler
and you make some packages But as time
went on it's like okay well but you need
to have the infrastructure for your for
your website for the packages and you
need to make sure the releases work on
all the different uh operating systems
and different chips and then there's
like this other stuff where it's like
you should be on Twitter and you should
write blogs and do talks and you should
be participating on GitHub and in the
forums um and then a bit later it's like
okay well there's also like people
running conferences and doing elmbridge
and like should you be providing some
structure to make sure that's happening
in a good way and so maybe you should
get some trademarks so that if someone's
going to run that kind of thing you can
make sure they have a code of conduct
and there's certain guidelines and if
you're going to do that probably you
need a foundation that's going to have
some accounting and you're going to have
to do taxes for that and you know my
attitude throughout all this was
like yeah I I can do it I can learn new
things um and at some point I kind of
realized like okay I can do I can do
these
things and I can do those things okay
but I'm just like I I'm getting crushed
by all this work so I took a step back
and I was like you know maybe you maybe
more than one person's like a good idea
um I don't know about 30 but like two or
three um and so I was like who pays for
these jobs and why are they doing that
and why why aren't they doing that to
me
um so I thought about it a lot and I
kind of came up with these two overall
categories of how languages are funded
um and so in corporate languages there's
a couple options independent languages
there there's a couple as well um and
with each option that's available
there's certain design incentives um and
there's certain career risks that come
along with
it um sorry my wife is texting me
probably good luck
um so yeah so before we get into all the
different options and all the different
trade-offs I want to take a step back
and talk about traffic acquisition costs
is anybody familiar with traffic
acquisition costs okay excellent
excellent um this is when Google pays to
be default search in Safari and in
Firefox um and this is probably the
largest flow of money into programming
languages happening right now um so
we're going to figure out how does this
work and sort of then come back to the
landscape for program pramming languages
so I went and read all of Google's uh
SEC filings for the last 20 years and we
don't we don't have to read them I made
it a diagram um so 2022 $283 billion is
flowing into Google um and if if we
split that between every person who's in
America that'd be
$880 for everybody so everyone you all
get 880 everyone you ever know everyone
they ever knew it's kind of a lot I
don't know
and that's going all these different
places and the one we care about is
traffic acquisition cost $49 billion and
what happens here is a big chunk of that
is going to Apple it's hard to get exact
numbers because no one lists it exactly
on their SEC findings um but there's
this firm uh that everyone references
when you ask this question and they
estimate that uh in 2021 it was $15
billion and in 2022 it was between 18
and 20 so let's just say it's 15 I I
don't know exactly um and you know they
go into their code and in seven places
they say google.com instead of bing.com
and then they're like thank you thank
you um and then fire Mozilla Corporation
also um so there's Mozilla Foundation
but Mozilla Corporation is where most
people are employed and the money flows
through um you can go read their yearly
reports and it's around 400 million
that's going into firef Fox for being
default search and so when I found this
out my first question was like why why
is it so much money it's like do you
just go to the website I don't get it um
and then second why is it so much for
the traffic acquisition cost is an
incredible amount so for why so much
revenue I I I got a list of the top
companies in the world by revenue and I
we're we're interested in number 18
Google um but I noticed some weird
things about uh this l I was like oil
and gas and then Commodities is like
people who sell oil and gas it's like
oil and gas Commodities oil and gas oil
and gas Commodities oil and gas Comm oil
and gas oil and gas oil and gas I was
like man I wonder if those people are
powerful and influential
um and the other thing I noticed is that
like right below Google is Toyota so
like all the Toyota cars that were
produced in the whole world in
2022 we collectively spent less money
than we did on whatever it is that
Google
does and so
um I I have this personal Theory I don't
know if it's true but I was like okay
what if they're like a landlord instead
of an Advertiser so in a traditional
landlord you have all these locations
and if you're in the shopping area maybe
you get some kind of rent and if you're
in the residential area and it's like a
wealthy residential area but maybe
you're in like you know it's Copenhagen
so it's like less wealthy residential
area um and part of what influences what
rent you can get at all these locations
is the transportation right so if you're
near a subway station that's probably a
better spot than if you're just out in
like this spot over here where there
there is a really nice swimming pool but
you you got to take the bus um and so
when I think of an Internet landlord the
transportation is different it's the
search box right you don't go on the bus
and you're not in a specific spe
location you just get in the search bar
and you go to the place and the place
isn't like the website you go to the
locations are shoes Street um and you
see all the storefronts on shoes street
that you can go to and it's tours of
Rome Street and you can see oh here's
all the shops that I can go to and when
I made these searches a few days ago I
noticed that every single link that is
visible to me is a sponsored link um on
both of them and so I think of it as
like okay these people are like paying
their rent to be right outside the train
station right in that first spot where
they're going to get the most foot
traffic and
so uh you know if you if you haven't
thought about what your opinions are on
landlords I can recommend this book
progress in
poverty um it's written by this guy who
moved to San Francisco in 1860 and then
he wrot wrote the book in 1881 and he
had this question is like I'm seeing
this incredible uh accumulation of
wealth but at the same time I'm seeing
this incredible poverty that is
happening at the same time why is that
happening um and you know you don't have
to listen to everything he says but on
landlords he he's very interesting and
so one idea that kind of comes out of
that is like what if you put a tax on
rent only um and he has a bunch of ideas
and like could you control um uh
regulate proper prices without price
controls through these other mechanisms
it's all very interesting um and you
know he also he's not a fan of landlords
but um but yeah so why so much revenue
this is like my theory that I'm going to
go with for the purpose of this talk
it's my opinion I don't know um so why
so much traffic acquisition costs well
again it's all about that search bar and
the people who own that search bar um
have a certain amount of browser market
share so with Firefox it's about 3% and
so Google's saying okay for 400 $
million we would like that 3% thank you
very much and with uh
Microsoft not for sale sorry this is
being territory we get the rents off of
this 5% we wish it was more but we get
it um and for Safari they're almost uh
20% and so our estimate was that it was
uh $15
billion and this is about to scale the
difference between um Firefox and and
Safari and then Chrome over
60% they don't pay nothing that's free
real estate
baby and so you can you say but okay
there are costs you have to make Chrome
and you have to make Android but we can
look at this and say well Firefox
they're making it for $400 million I
wonder if having 60% of the real estate
covers that
um and so instead of wondering why is it
so high the better question is like why
is it so low right this there's this
incredible achieve achievement um with
chrome that's permitting these uh
amazing profits that they're seeing or
Revenue that they're seeing also profits
um so I went and looked at Microsoft's
SEC filings as well and I found an
interesting thing which is that when you
look at their search and news
advertising it's 12 billion so if they
dedicated 100% of their revenue to being
default search in on Apple products they
can't afford it it's like okay we're
going to turn off the servers we're
gonna fire everybody we're just only the
money is going to you and it's like ah
are we going to give up3 billion to put
Bing on all our phones it's like even if
we wanted to would we do it for $3
billion less um so what are the
practical consequences in terms of
languages for this um so we have all
this crazy amount of money and going
into
um and they're doing stuff with it and
so one of the things they buy is
developer relations um devil and so
these are different kinds of jobs so you
have developer evangelists you know
they're spreading the good word and
there's Advocates fighting for justice
uh and Community managers building up
our community stronger um and so I don't
I didn't know what these were so I went
and looked up and I found okay so
evangelists do conferences and meetups
okay Advocates support online channels
writing tutorials guides templates
collecting feedback for developers which
is crucial because you get the feedback
but you don't get the interpersonal
reaction interaction of uh someone being
like you
suck someone nice says hey people think
you suck and say
okay I like I that's what I like to hear
instead um and then Community managers
make sure everything's running smoothly
and this is just one person's definition
of these things but you know maybe this
person's um running Twitter or if
there's like a heated conversation they
help explain like why decisions were
made and help it cool down um and some
of you may be thinking man this sure
sounds a lot like marketing and support
but it's not that it's not that it's
evangelism it's
advocacy it's community
building and by the way programmers
we're not susceptible to marketing we
can't be persuaded of anything and we
don't need help we'll just figure it out
ourselves um so okay so all that's
happening and we just we don't talk
about the money part we're getting the
benefits of all this Deval and then for
some random person you don't have all
that money coming in and what you get is
the open source way so I found this um
through opensource.com at link to this
and it was very interesting because it
it was telling me the way is something
like this a person creates the first
iteration and they have the special
insight and they find the exact solution
that no one else could find and then
they give that away right and so other
people start using it and from those
users arise enthusiasts and they promote
the software I was like oh that's crazy
you get free devil that's crazy because
when Google does it they pay for the
devil though so why is it that when I do
it it's going to be free um and then
step four arising from the users come
people contributing to the software and
it's like oh that's incredible free
compiler Engineers it's like that's
quite a specialist education and you
know now that I think of it when Google
does it they they pay those people to do
those things why is it that I'm going to
get those things for free so maybe in
step five they'll explain how that part
Works no okay okay so okay so you take
good care of your users right okay okay
I get it I get it okay so I'll read on
so okay step one you attract users right
so you do the marketing you do um and
then you guide the participants and help
them understand the goals of the project
you know it sounds a little bit like
onboarding if you working with someone
um and then you grow the contributors
and um so you do the mentorship right
and you do that for free and also you're
doing the development you're doing that
for free right and so step four right
like because when because when Google
does it they pay for all those things so
but when I do it what's when where's the
step where where that happens it's like
okay no there's not that for it's like a
dance party oh right it's like a dance
party and we want to have a dance party
around the world okay I okay I get it
now and so what happens is that because
we never talk about these huge flows of
money and what they're getting us we
have the same expectations of what's
going to happen in both these cases so
as a language designer people are saying
to you why isn't why isn't this
happening in the blogs why isn't this
happening over there it's like okay I
well I I don't have $400
million I mean I'm
sorry but um so how did we get to this
place where there's this the
expectations match but the situation is
so different um and so I think about it
as like we have switching costs when you
want to switch from one programming
environment to another that can be quite
difficult and then you have the added
issue of Microsoft and so historically
what that meant is like people were
making their online businesses on
Internet Explorer and they're like this
is cool we're making money on the
internet and then well there are these
other browsers and they wanted to make
money over there but if they wanted to
there was this switching cost they had
to pay and what the people in Microsoft
realized is that if we take advantage of
this switching cost well we can make
some money instead and so the
relationship between these organizations
was out of whack and so um open source
comes um to resolve this conflict so the
term open source actually came from um
the company Netscape they were having a
lot of trouble with um bugs and stuff
and so they said okay if we release all
of our code the hackers around the world
we're going to harness that that was the
word they use in their press release
we're going to harness them to improve
our code and that's going to save us
from Microsoft um and that was the birth
of Mozilla the Mosaic killer um and so
the setup of this is that on the one
side we have the platform developer
who's making the browsers and the other
side we have app developers who want to
be in that Marketplace like they say
okay I'm going to pay rent for the
storefront and I'm want to be there um
and they're making websites but maybe
they're making mobile apps or desktop
apps it'd be the same for them and so we
have an agreement here and when the code
is given away we follow these certain
rules so it's like Google shouldn't be
able to discriminate against field of
endeavor it's like why should they be
able to say what people can do when
they're participating in this
Marketplace or competing to be the
landlord of the marketplace um and
there's all these rules that make a lot
of sense and what we get is this really
incredible achievement
where for um what what we do is those
big companies do their traffic
acquisition costs and they do their anti
fragmentation agreements and they do
their mobile application distribution
agreements and you can go read about
those um and we we don't talk about it
we don't think about it it's not our
problem we just have no switching cost
if the control of the platform changes
hands we can do our business over here
we can do our business over there the
flow of traffic it comes to us we pay
rent to whoever's the landlord it
doesn't matter to us
um and I I mean I got to say it's like
that's definitely a really cool
achievement that sort of in a collective
way we found this way to have these two
things coexist um should those things
traffic acquisition cost and all that
exist I don't I don't that's a separate
question um so from here the question is
like is this great achievement
generalizable right so can this solve
the switching class plus Microsoft
problem for all cases so in theory we
have some author and it doesn't matter
who and they give away the code and they
do so following the open source way and
when Google does it we say yeah it makes
sense if Microsoft gets a code who cares
like they can go fight each other it's
no problem um but when an individual
does it it doesn't work quite the same
way because one you have the cost of
developing the language and two you have
the cost of developing a business and
for other people who get the code they
just have the cost of developing the
business so there's this natural
disadvantage of producing it when it
comes to making money um and the costs
of developing the language are
significant right so we have the design
and implementation the marketing the
onboarding the mentoring and you have to
do the mentoring because that's how you
get the free devil and the free compiler
engineers and these are ongoing costs
you know it's not like oh language is
over good good work everyone
um and you know the person you're giving
all this away to is Amazon and they say
okay well he's trying to do this kind of
business it's like let's just put five
people on it and we'll have it instead
and we'll have a bigger market and and
you just lose um and the issue is it's
not just Amazon but it's like any
organization that's larger than you so
if I'm an individual and I can work on
the programming language 50% of my time
and trying to do the business side 50%
of my time if someone wanted to do a
better job than me they just need one
person to work like 60% of the
time and so like this is a huge um
a huge disadvantage in this particular
case so um for me the question that
comes from this is there a way to
address the switching costs problem um
that provides a clear pathway for small
authors it's not like oh we want to like
add we want to be Microsoft it's just
like we want to we want people to feel
comfortable they're like if they don't
like the thing they switch to something
else but um how do you solve this uh
asymmetry so finally we can return to
all the different ways um and so so
we'll start with corporate languages
where traffic acquisition costs are a
major factor um so uh style one is just
a company specific platform so this
would be like Swift or C you got all the
money coming in because you're selling
the phones you've got the app store you
put Google in the search bar you changed
the seven lines and you're like yeah 10
people on
Swift okay sure um and there's also the
corporate Alliance style so this would
be more like JavaScript where there's a
technical committee tc39 where all these
companies can come together and kind of
negotiate how things should evolve to
support the maximum uh user base and
create the biggest Marketplace and have
the most Commerce flowing and we just
we're just collecting rents who gets the
market shared that's our business um and
so this would happen more in a contested
platform kind of scenario and the two
parts is like for reducing traffic
acquisition costs like Google they're
producing Chrome and Android which are
um really cool virtual machine work is
happening there and then increasing
traffic acquisition costs so you have
Firefox and Safari very cool virtual
machine working happening there as well
but also rust because how I think about
it is that um the way Google kind of
rose to its colossal market share is
that they had the good performance and
the stability and a lot of the things
that I heard about Russ was we're going
to make uh Firefox faster we're going to
improve the stability and maybe we can
use that same technique to move up our
market share and move up our traffic
acquisition costs and you know people
here about Firefox and there'll be some
brand uh
benefits um and finally rewarding Talent
this is like the weird one of this group
um because only Google really does it so
one example is Dart the person who made
Dart Lars Bach um was the technical lead
for the V8 engine on Chrome and so like
the technical success of that that it
was faster and the pages were loading
faster and the applications were working
better like Google essentially rode that
to having a great reputation being
widely used and just like all that free
real estate that comes with that and
then also no one talks about it it's
just like wow they're so generous giving
away this stuff for free because they
love
us um and the other one is uh yeah so so
the point there is like when when Lars
says Hey can I have 30 guys it's like
yeah yeah I me that
all uh
I'm sure it's it's more complicated than
that but like you know you you've earned
something in terms of your reputation
with with the company when you do
something like that go is a interesting
one because the Creator before they did
go did this language called sawall which
is about processing logs and you might
say who cares about processing logs why
do you get to make a programming
language now um so when someone goes to
Sho Street and they click on you know
the best the the the top uh location
well that that click gets written into
the logs so Google knows okay they're
going to be paying us a lot of money but
they they don't actually know how much
and so they have to go process the logs
to make the bills for everyone so he
essentially made the machine that counts
the money and so it's like okay you want
three people it's like whatever that's
fine and so one thing to note here is
that of all the languages and projects
we talked about the only one that's like
not obviously connected to traffic
acquisition costs is C it's like it's FL
into all these projects huge huge huge
ounts of
money and then with independent
languages that's just not happening this
is a world where like all that money
doesn't exist but the expectations of
what you should be producing and how
quickly and what it should look like are
all the same for some
reason um so in this one there's a bunch
one the most high-profile is uh
patronage which is kind of the style of
python you know python is probably the
most successful of like independent
languages um but okam is similar Elm had
that kind of thing um and the great
thing about this is that you're able to
focus 100% on the language there's
someone else is doing the business
that's their business and you know the
downside is that well it's their
business so if their things change for
them well they change for you too and so
how well you're doing what's going on
with the language it's kind of
independent of what happens to you um
and so the next one I think this is kind
of the most productive uh one is
Consulting so we've got closure Elixir
Scola Julia and I'm sure there's others
that do it as well um and in this case
language usage probably correlates with
number of clients so like as you have
more work to handle you also will be
able to have more resources to handle
that work um you know I I haven't done
this but my I imagine that you know
having more clients means having more
work and so it's not like oh great now
that it's more successful I get to work
on the language more it's like okay now
I have all this other stuff to manage as
well as doing the language as well and
so so you have this contested resources
situation next is research grants hasal
camel schola um this one's awesome
because it's if if your the grants are
flowing you just do cool stuff um the
downside is that the language has to be
a good research vehicle like the point
is to explore things um and if that's
not what you want to do then well you
have to do that um and there's not going
to be a devil budget like DARPA doesn't
care like the conference is the academic
conferences don't care it's just not
going to happen um this we're starting
to get into the weirder ones here editor
licenses cotlin is the only example I
know of this um and again languages
which probably correlates with number of
licenses but the the trouble is that you
have to make a fancy editor like and
that's a really hard thing to do well
and so if someone was starting out as an
individual I'd say you know probably the
editor needs to come first otherwise
it's going to take too long um because
it turns out taking a language making
language takes a long time I didn't know
that
um so usage licenses okay these actually
exist um so St and Wolfram language for
Mathematica are just straight up
licensed it's like oh you want to use
it pay me and the reason for that is
that they're in uh they're used by
academic institutions so it's like if
you're an economist and you want to
continue being an economist your
institution needs to give you access to
data um so that you can participate in
how the research works there and um so
for this one let's imagine that it's not
that model which seems wouldn't make
sense in a like a commercial setting and
you say okay what if there existed a
language that um was free to use but for
commercial users there was some license
fee um so in this one it's cool because
you can focus 100% on the language when
you do a good job on the language like
that's what people are paying you for
there's no extra part there's no
managing all these clients and ah that
client's kind of annoying but like pay
good and um but the issue is there's no
established solution to the switching
Cost question it's just like it totally
makes sense that if someone doesn't like
the thing anymore it should be easy to
switch off and there should be a pathway
for that um but but what would it look
like in this one I don't know um next is
hosting uh I don't know a lot about
datomic but that's kind of what I have
in my mind as the example of this and
again the good thing is that language
usage probably correlates with number of
clients for the hosting
um but the downside is the Jeff problem
so the issue is that um it's Jeff Bezos
he's out there he's looking for you so
we've got this open source definition
where Google they give those stuff away
to Microsoft that works and then we have
this other thing where like you have to
do the development cost you have to do
the cost of bills and they do the cost
of developing the business too but
they're Amazon so they say oh you want
to do hosting that's cool like we'll
just do it more and do it to more people
and start to cannibalize your business
but you know I said to myself well
there's one thing that Jeff can't do and
that's make a simple easy to use
interface and
so no no matter what I have I have this
competitive advantage that like I can do
that and I can especially do it cuz I
don't really have time to do a super
Advanced one um but what I failed to see
when I was first thinking about this was
that it's not just Jeff like I can get
Jeff by anybody um
so a friend I know he could Jeff me a
company down the street I could get jeed
by them and it's no hard feelings it's
like they want to do a hosting business
I want it's like yeah it's it's no
problem but you would Jeff me you would
Jeff
me
so uh the the final one is uh donations
and I don't know of any examples of
languages doing this it might exist but
I don't know of it um and theoretically
it would correlate with language usage
but the downside is that your career is
very strongly related to public
perception so it may be the case that
your language is used by like hundreds
of thousands millions of people but if
you're not present in the minds of those
people like that's going to affect you
right um so now we have enough
background to think about some of the
design incentives here so one of the
decision you have to make is should I
add this future yes and in the case you
say yes you're probably going to have
less conflict it's going to be more
pleasant
interactions um and in the case of no
you're going to have less complexity
which is that's good too I mean they're
both kind of nice um but in different
environments you're going to get
different incentives to go one way or
the other so in the corporate Alliance
maybe some company wants once this wild
JavaScript feature they say it's not I
don't like accessing the field X I want
that to have side effects
um so but and you say okay but why mess
with the alliance you know like the
point of this is we're trying to take
over the world we're trying to have the
biggest Marketplace in the world and the
most Commerce going through it so they
need that for their business um and yeah
let's just add it and if people don't
like it they cannot use it they can put
it in their style guides they can put it
in their linter that we don't care like
what we want is the marketplace to be as
big as possible um so with a research V
um maybe some researcher investigate
independent types it's very interesting
and here you ask why mess with the
research just like literally why like
that's the whole point of everything
we're doing the point is to do research
and find out how different features
interact with each other and it's just
like I can't even in my mind imagine a
scenario where you'd want to say no
unless it like breaks everything but
like I guess that's research too um so
here you have these yes incentives and
then with independent authors say
someone wants some new syntax or this or
that okay but here it's like why I mess
with it kind of depends on what the
author is trying to achieve right and
they all have their idea of like maybe
some of them do want to have a high
market share or explore certain ideas or
maybe they want this very specific
developer experience or maybe they want
some combination of all those things and
so you might ask yourself like why mess
with Simplicity you know or why mess
with the Lambda calculus I mean why even
have numbers you know like uh there it
just depends on the author um what where
you're going to go there so here the
incentives aren't so clear and it kind
of depends on knowing what the language
is trying to do um and so yeah I wanted
to emphasize I've never heard anybody of
any designer or person who works in the
language that have said I had to make a
choice I don't think this is something
where like bosses are telling people you
have to do this you have to do that but
it's more that in a specific context you
kind of like I'll say in my example like
There features language features that I
like that I know Elm it Elm wouldn't
like them like it's Elm doesn't want
that and in the same way like when
you're in these other environments you
can kind of tell okay what this language
what it needs is this um and like what I
want I mean that's separate like I'll
work on my own programming language in
my free time which I know a lot of VM
people do and stuff um so okay on Career
risks uh I know the most about uh
patronage because I I I was very
fortunate to have some people support my
work but here you have a job because it
serves the purpose of a powerful person
and what I mean is if someone can look
at you and say you you don't have to
worry about food or shelter you can work
on this thing and they can just as
easily say actually not you you you can
work on this thing over here it's like
that's power um and so what what are the
purposes of that person and what happens
when their purposes change right like if
these people are running a business
maybe the business environment Changs
changes or maybe they have a VC looking
over their shoulder and they're saying
you know that column over there with
that open source guy what are we really
doing there you know it's like I I hear
you're going for another round soon what
are we what are we doing over there and
so like it's not even like something
anyone necessarily thinks about it's not
like a VC person knows like what it
takes to make a programming language
they just see the column and they say
the column over
um no they're smart they're smart
um um so yeah so the question becomes
like is doing a good job on the language
deeply related to their purposes um and
like when I was working at at prei as a
concrete example um they had this
situation where their application was
written in flash and flash was going
away so they're saying okay it looks
like we have to rewrite to
JavaScript uh Android iOS and desktop so
it's not just that we're rewriting our
whole product but we're rewriting it
four times at the same time and so they
said let's hire this kid and see if like
this programming language can help
reduce the cost of like essentially for
Xing what we have to do to um to
continue and you know I was young we
didn't know we didn't know how long it
took to make a programming language
turns out it's it's more than like a
year
um but um but yeah at some point it was
like okay it's clear that this other
path is going to work and so that was
over and it's not like oh I have hard
feelings like I only have gratitude that
they supported my work and believed in
me that I could help with that um but it
didn't work out um and it wasn't like I
did a bad job but in my head I said okay
the only thing I really can do here is
just work hard like make the value of my
output undeniable no one can look at it
and say well he actually isn't even good
at it you know they have to look at him
and say some other thing you they have
to look at the column they have to look
at something else and what was difficult
is that this doesn't really work like
ultimately your efforts and achievements
aren't directly connected to your
ability to pay the bills it's just like
something else is happening um and I I
didn't know that going into um
going into these relationships and had I
known that probably 2015 2016 I would
have tried to you know you know I'm not
going to if you want to patronize this
great but I'm also going to try to
develop the Consulting path and I'm not
personally like the guy for that but I
should have I wish I had known like try
to find a business partner who can do
these kinds of things and you're
bringing something valuable like you're
bringing uh reputation and you're going
to drive incoming leads but like maybe
you don't answer emails that good or
like uh on time or and people find it
really annoying and it's like okay but
okay but we we Partners right um so the
other one so this is kind of like we're
just pretending that these exist um and
just thinking about them um
so with donations people donate because
of their own personal reasons um and
it's really hard to know those I mean
even the person donating just have a
feeling that I want to do that and if
you ask them well why do you want to do
that they' be
like I am I don't know like and I mean
also why why ask say good
um um but on the hosting site people are
using the service because it suits their
needs and preferences like they have a
test they want to do and this is helping
them do it and that's valuable to them
and in each case you're going to get
different samples of the people using
your language um and so in the donations
case it's not a representative sample so
like
with python I would imagine that most
people who use Python don't know who
Guido van rossom is um and let alone of
the people who do would they know that
there's a way to do donations and of
them so you're getting this very
particular sample size or sample um and
with hosting you'd get more of a full
range of people using language um and so
in with in both these cases you're going
to have some questions in the back of
your mind when you're trying to make
decisions and so like on this side you
have like are the donators going to
approve of this and the donators are
going to have all kinds of opinions of
like okay I I like where you're going
but I think it should go faster and it
should cost less and um or actually we
should be going in a slightly different
direction and that's you know that's
just a natural thing because like even
within a company it's hard to um get
everyone to agree to a direction to go
and and in this case there's the
relationship's inverted um and so on the
other side it's like will it be easier
to make websites and it's like kind of a
measurable thing like you you do the
thing that you believe will work and
then the results are it works or it
doesn't work and it's on your technical
results not what people think the
technical results will be if they are
completed at a future date um and so I
had this feeling that this would be a
much healthier work environment and
there'd be more time for the technical
work you could make more long-term
Investments
um and again the thing I didn't realize
is that it's not just Jeff who can Jeff
you but anybody can Jeff you um and so
okay so that that ends the portion of
the talk where I know about things and
then sharing experiences but so I had
this idea it seems like hosting would be
cool and well Jeff can't Jeff me and
these other people I'm not thinking
about them right now um and I was like I
have this idea I'm just going to sit
here and I'm going to think about it cuz
I think I can compile Elm to C and SQL
and have it run on post grass and I can
support custom types in the table so in
the columns I can have my May and
results and anything you can think of
and I can have a dense binary format for
that and I can use it over the wire so
there's no encoding and decoding and the
same way that I check the types of when
you do package publication I can do that
on tables and detect oh we need to do a
migration
here um I was like I think it's there
and the crazy thing is that it's there I
I I have it on my computer it's like it
it's like I it's not like done done but
it's like I can do my little demo and
everything um and then I'm like wow
that's crazy anyway I remember I needed
to think about the Jeff problem more and
then I was like oh I'm gonna get Jeff
I'm gonna get Jeff by
everybody and so it's just it's just on
my computer like I don't know what to do
um and that's the economics of
programming languages I just don't know
what to
do
[Applause]
so I have some closing things uh to to
ask of people or to think about and so
one to authors of these kinds of
projects um I just want to say the open
source way is for businesses um you
can't come into it just like wanting to
do a good job you have to figure out
these other kinds of things you have to
think about all these options and how
they'll interact with what you want to
do for your language and then to people
in this room and everyone else I just
hope that we'll try to tell young people
it's not what you read online it's not
what people say in forums it's like
there's all this other stuff going on
and I don't think we should let that
happen to young people
um um uh to users um I I think this
system for me helps me look at languages
in a better way so I'm able to ask are
the goals with a specific language um
maybe they're trying to have the biggest
user base possible maybe they're trying
to explore ideas maybe they have some
particular thing they're interested in
um and what's the situation of the
author is it a big Corporation a little
company a person is there a venture
capitalist standing over their shoulder
standing over their shoulder and you
know because the way someone's going to
design a language is going to be
different if there's someone being like
you know you could probably tighten the
screws a little bit over there um where
the money is
um um and then try to evaluate the
trade-offs if they suit your needs right
like not all these languages are going
to produce the same thing and so if you
want to have the Deval out there like
you're probably going to want to go with
a corporate language it's no no problem
it's just that's what you'd want to do
and if you want some more Niche
experience um you're going to want to go
with an independent language but you're
not going to get all the same things um
and so yeah and also like there's your
needs and then there's also your
preferences which is like okay I have I
know what I need and what I prefer is
kind of like a separate thing um and so
yeah so when I when I look at languages
I can look at them or I like to look at
them and
say okay what was their specific goal
okay I don't necessarily share that goal
but that's what it was and then how did
they solve that with language design and
it's always something inspiring and you
can always look at a language and find
something inspiration and cool about it
even if for me it's like well I don't
need to do that I don't that's not how I
want to do things but I can still find
inspiration and be glad that I saw that
and it's out there um so I wanted to
leave with two final questions what did
you think of that uh internet landlord
idea like what even would be the
implications of that um if there's this
thing collecting rent off of all of us
is like is that is that is that bad I I
don't know I don't know I just literally
don't know um and then is there a way to
address the switching costs that has a
clear pathway for small authors again I
don't know um but you know if you do
know uh I'm Evan CZ and you can just
tell me on Twitter or Elm slacker or
Gmail um and if you're using Elm I can
show you a little demo it's on my
computer um but yeah I just I don't know
what to do and that's economics of
program languages thank
[Applause]
you